hey 42 here Sean Connery was once pulled
over and fined by British police for
speeding the officer's name was Sergeant
James Bond welcome to RIF the entire
Super Mario Brothers game was only 40
kilobytes the average console game today
is over 1 million times that size
contrary to popular belief the pyramids
were not built by slaves but by well-fed
skilled laborers who were given proper
housing in the 2004 harvard-yale
American football game Yale students
tricked thousands of Harvard fans into
holding up cards that together spelt out
we sock Google is working on a fully
modular smartphone with replaceable
parts so you can upgrade and repair
individual parts without ever having to
buy a new phone
40% of humanity lives in countries where
it's illegal to be homosexual nearly 3
percent of the ice in Antarctica Lasius
is penguin Yuri the brain of the
colossal squid is doughnut shaped and
its esophagus runs through it therefore
if it eats something too big it could
get brain damage whilst British MPs are
speaking in Parliament they are exempt
from defamation laws this allows them to
insult each other in any way they choose
without legal consequence when howling
together no two wolves will howl with
the same note instead they harmonize to
create the illusion that there are more
of them than there actually are more
salt is used around the world for
de-icing roads than for human
consumption during a car crash 40
percent of drivers never even hit the
brakes the first ever shopping mall was
an ancient robe built in 100 AD it was
named Trajan's market it was four
stories tall with 150 shops and offices
at room temperature the average air
molecule travels at the speed of a
bullet for
my rifle every day between 10 and 20
volcanoes are erupting somewhere on
earth if you count for 24 hours a day it
would take you over 31,000 years to
reach 1 trillion thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42